hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's my favorite slow motion
conservative Bill Maher saying something
that conservatives said a while back and
then he says it and everybody applauds
him for it
finally new rule everybody should be
allowed to let themselves go a couple of
times a year like now the dog days this
summer school's out rules out it's hot
vacation time no one should have to diet
on vacation and the holidays that's the
other okay I'll let myself go time a
year and who can blame us it's the end
of the year
structured around feast days
no one should feel bad about opening up
the pants after Thanksgiving dinner and
doing that thing where you undo the top
button and try to hold it together with
just the belt
that's all fine
but not all year round
and that's what's kind of happened to
America letting ourselves go now as an
all year round thing doing the
Thanksgiving pants thing every day
[Applause]
actually really sell a business suit now
with drawstring pants
I swear I saw this in the mall and I
said to the salesman this is pathetic it
shows how much we've given up and he
said no people love it
they love it you can have a mongoose for
lunch and then
give that big presentation
there's a disturbing Trend going on in
America these days rewriting science
to fit ideology or just to fit what you
want reality to be we've gone from fat
acceptance to Fat celebration
that's new
that is new
to view letting yourself go as a point
of pride
we used to at least try and be fit and
healthy and Society praised those who
succeeded now the term body positivity
is used to mean I'm perfect the way I am
because I'm me
it's orwellian how often positivity is
used to describe what's not healthy
of course you can get away with anything
bad for you when you're young but let me
ask you this have you ever seen a fat 90
year old
healthy at any weight
is an unchallenged lie that people tell
themselves or they can go on eating
whatever they want which is fine I've
done many self-destructive things too
but no one pretended there was
positivity in smoking
fat activist Ted Kyle founder of
conscient Health says the media and
public needs to stop catastrophizing
obesity
okay a they're not catastrophizing it
and B they should be
because it's a full-blown catastrophe
poor diet is the leading cause of
mortality in the United States
New York Times okay of course we're
talking about heart disease and cancer
and diabetes but also as covet has
taught us obesity is horrible for the
immune system which is why those numbers
were off the charts during the pandemic
that's a catastrophe it's literally a
national security issue now military
recruitment is down by the most since
the end of the draft because mainly 17
to 24 year olds are too fat to fight
at some point acceptance becomes
enabling
and if you're in any way participating
in this joyful celebration of gluttony
that goes on now you have blood on your
hands full stop
foreign
you can make believe you're fighting
some great social justice battle for a
besieged minority but what you're really
doing is enabling addicts which I
thought we decided was bad
it's not just the drawstring business
suits companies like Nike
Sports Illustrated Victoria's Secret
companies that are specifically about
Fitness nevertheless promote people who
are plainly not into fitness
people like Adele
face shame campaigns for losing weight
this is madness there's a reason the
first thing your doctor does is make you
step on a scale well
it used to be there's a card now that
you can give your doctor and it says
please don't weigh me unless it's really
medically necessary
it's always necessary
it's like asking your dentist not to
look at your teeth
[Music]
there's a popular t-shirt that says I
don't own no man a flat stomach
okay no one said you did
you do you but you're not a freedom
fighter because you want to keep eating
Donuts
USA Today actually wrote the sentence
science hasn't yet figured out how to
solve obesity
foreign
and Ted Kyle concurs saying we don't
know how to blunt the rise in obesity
because we don't know precisely what the
factors are that are causing it
yes what could it be what's what damn it
this is a hard one